curious is the mariana trench a great
place to put
carbon sequestering because it's so far
down or would would would this stuff
even make it all the way down i wonder
i don't know well i don't know i've
never we've never modeled it out that
deep never been to the mariana trench
no i've never been never been talk to uh
jim cameron i think he's
the only person who's really been there
yeah i'd be i'm sure he'd have that i'm
sure he has some stories about it too
but um
the uh yeah i think that
depth is critical you want to be deep
enough that the physics become in your
favor and sort of like compressibility
of the gases and
you know you don't you don't want carbon
or methane to be like coming back up
but um there's a little bit more to it
than that where we also want to make
sure that we're
um you know at least in our model we
think that
the the best way to do this is to spread
it out over a large area
that has the appropriate biogeochemistry
to like kind of encourage
the formation of kind of like deep
carbon composite deposits
um so it's it's there's some
specificity to where you put them at
least in the model that we're trying to
kind of
uh would creating oyster farms also help
with the sequestering problem yeah
absolutely yeah that's like every
no that's that's actually how we started
um we're we're like predominantly a
shellfish company and then this this
kelp was always on the road map but we
started to pull it forward as we saw the
um
the market start to develop um where
there's you know
all these companies so actually the what
we started with
is you know figuring out ways that we
could
harvest shellfish and you know using you
know sensors
like using sensors and data systems and
robotics to
harvest shellfish in the most efficient
way possible and develop the highest
quality product you know the goal is to
refine
all of these systems so that they're um
you know scalable and we're able to
you know meet me meet the
enormity of the demand coming right as
as uh
how do you fund the kelp farming uh
and this distribution of kelp is this
something you think governments will pay
for
or you'll get carbon credits for this
and then be able to sell them
to the car companies yeah that won't
make car
make uh you know uh evs
yeah i mean i think that there's a bunch
of different mechanisms right now we're
operating in a voluntary market where
like most of
these super you know the progressive
companies um
the progressive companies with a lot of
cash are making uh commitments
in response to consumers um and and
their own ethical you know in the you
know the ethical guidelines of the ceos
or whatever
management teams but they're uh they're
making commitments to be
uh zero carbon and you know a lot of
that is like buying renewable energy and
like establishing renewable energy for
their facilities but a lot of it
is going to have to come through
negative emissions so um
so somebody like apple or google who've
made the amazon who've made these
commitments publicly
carbon neutral 2030. they're not going
to get their solar panels yeah
they're not going to give money to you
they're going to need to give you 50
million a year 100 million a year
to go ship some uh help out there and
and then
sequester some carbon that's right and
that's like a first that's
that's great that these voluntary
markets are exist i'm
super happy that there's that that level
of interest out there and i think that
you know as as time goes on you know
when you look at the level of effort
required
this is going to look a lot more like a
um you know a world war on carbon and so
and it's going to be uh it's going to
require i think it's going to require
governments to step in
and to you know
accelerate these efforts